nous allons refuser du monde pour la
première fois de l'histoire des Restos
du cœur cette hausse massive et brutale
n'était jamais arrivée elle avait été
constaté en 2008 suite à la à la crise
financière mais de manière beaucoup plus
lente là ce qui surprend tout le monde
c'est le côté massif et brutal de cette
crise donc on a pris des mesures
restriction de l'accès baisse de la
dotation nous allons aussi donner moins
en quantité mais on a une inconnue c'est
l'appel à la générosité du public il y a
eu un appel des restos et il y a eu des
réponses des entreprises et on les
remercie il y a eu des réponses du grand
public mais est-ce que cette générosité
va être là aussi en en décembre ça c'est
la première question et la deuxième
question c'est que quand on regarde nos
nos suivis d'activités et nos
statistiques et ben on ne voit pas de
baisse donc ce qui veut dire que même en
réduisant les critères d'accès à partir
de novembre on a une grande inconnu sur
le fait que finalement il y aura
peut-être plus de personnes qui vont se
présenter quand même au resto et qui
seront j'allais dire éligibles selon nos
critères les restos du cœur sont pas
dimensionnés aujourd'hui pour accueillir
170 millions de repas en tout cas pour
distribuer 170 millions de repas pour
accueillir 1,3 million de personnes
puisque c'est 200000 personnes de plus
en un an qui sont allés taper à la porte
des restos on est pas taillé humainement
même si nous avons 70000 bénévoles
réguliers et 30000 bénévoles ponctuels
on n'est pas taillé humainement comme
nous disent euh les B vole sur le
terrain c'est de l'abattage et c'est pas
le rôle des Restos du cœur le rôle des
Restos du cœur c'est d'accueillir l'aide
alimentaire est un point d'entrée pour
accompagner pour orienter pour les
orienter vers l'accès au droit et pour
essayer de faire sortir ces personnes de
la précarité